what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to start up
and or today John how are you I am
excited how are you I'm very excited
I've heard great things about this show
we're really great things about it and
I'm pretty excited I watched Rogue one
at the IMAX re-release still looks good
after all these years it still looks
great so yeah I'm excited to jump into
this but guys we got three episodes out
right now so please leave a like it's
the first request that we have for you
all second Wing subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next episode of and
or is up here on the Chanel as always
full-length Reaction watch alongs where
you sync up with your own copy of and or
available for our super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page also cover a
bunch of shows over there exclusively
with reaction highlights of watchalongs
included and lastly the team at prepper
thank you for helping us set it down
these highlights let's get this show on
the road
[Music]
thank you
feels like a 80s sci-fi movie
it's like the beginning of alien
does have like a Ridley Scott Flair to
this I was gonna say it's got like a
blade runnery
Vibe
[Music]
someone's watching Tron legacy don't
even think about it
just anyone crying
I say go for it and or
a friend of mine said there was a girl
for Canary working here it's not your
girlfriend or something is it I don't
have a girlfriend
otherwise why would I be here nostalgic
are we let me go and check on that for
you
Star Wars erotica I never thought I'd
see a brothel in this universe you keep
looking I'll realize there's something
funny definitely not
what does that mean oh that is a hard
look for a little thing like you yeah
he's not laughing now is he there was a
girl from Canary but she left several
months ago any idea where she went what
are you
seriously boyfriend husband are you a
cop Latino
I'm really enjoying the tone of this
yeah it's so dreary and like dreddy
tough break
when he swam over swim over scroll now
he's not laughing anymore you've got
Corporal ID now a bit of time to pull it
out you have to see it big stuff
there you go
cool way to do that I got 300 credits in
my code pocket
ouch
oh the pocket
oh yeah
tell me now
tell me what to do get him up
oh my God
don't breathing together we played too
hard in heaven and you didn't understand
that you try to grab you and but he felt
everything he said I'll tell you what
happened whoa
cast shot first
best new star war oh and it looks great
by the way yes
so tense
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
I need to remember my whole life story
before we begin before I joined the
Rebellion
oh yes
[Music]
but where were you it's not important
if it's not important why not tell me
listen to me that's important I know it
takes a lot of energy but can you make a
life with me Mike I'm lied I have
adequate power reserved
don't tell anybody you know where I am
we have two lies a Toughbook
I gotta hurry I can't come with you not
now I don't have time
oh buddy
take your time
the fact that this Droid is not in Rogue
one has me worried I know
don't worry we got at least 24 episodes
we decided we were thirsty and you
wanted to go to Cabos but I said that
was no good because there's too many
people there I owe money you're serious
yeah so covers was out
but then you remember you still had half
a bottle of milk stashed at home
so we went there and drank ourselves to
sleep
please
I really needed this
that's a lot to remember to Dedicated
primor employees caught in the sad orbit
of a calamity
I don't understand I want you to come to
a suitable accident but and let's make
sure it's on the far side of the plaza
let's get it outside the Leisure Zone
but they were murdered no they were
killed in a fight they're in the brothel
which we're not supposed to have the
expensive one which they shouldn't be
able to afford they clearly harassed a
human with dark features and chose the
wrong person to annoy I suspect they
died rushing to Aid someone in distress
nothing to Hero my God Jesus I got an
untraceable ns9 star path unit Vector
crystals and Imperial seal still intact
looks like it's turned into something
more than work do I ask about your
personal life just just promise he knows
nothing about any of this he'd do
anything for me
no no no
he knows nothing about any of it this
you said he wanted to meet me I really
need this I'll let him know I really
believe the history
[Laughter]
she's tougher than both of us I'm
getting tired of hearing that you better
find yourself a less complicated woman
[Laughter]
I don't speak Spanish
I do like how they've kept it in their
native tongue yeah instead of pray
[ __ ]
what is that sub life something all in
Star cab or Dave and Son old thing
whatever it is I want to know when it
left and where it went you'd have to
filter the entire night well there's too
much for you let me know I'm sure
somebody wants the chair he's the
Commissioner Gordon of the corporate
office
I want my deposit back I wish I could
but it's in play seriously I'm not one
of these losers Gonna Let You float
until they forget how much you owe them
he let him talk you into this the
subject is money just ask you a question
what since when you take orders from
nurture don't answer that you need to
work this bad leave him out of it he
said all I need you to do is stand here
hahaha
you're killing it man I'm gonna do us a
favor and not mention this happened
veg very nice to see you
guys
I'll be back
don't be long yeah
what are you doing
[Music]
the start of a healthy relationship
foreign
good luck with it oh this is where the
grips put all their stuff there's not a
lot about qunari sir it's fairly obscure
that should make it easier we'll have to
put the word out fireworks where else
would we put it we don't have presents
there sir is it not under our
jurisdiction technically we are simply
asking for information have you ever
been there what difference does that
make they have their own way of doing
things this is the murder of two primo
employees
oh oh Canary human men wanted for
questioning slam the channels flooded
set up a desk here to monitor anything
that comes in let's go
he was an honor student what he was
you're gonna get us both in trouble I
didn't like the way it was running last
night
so you do me a favor no more favors no
more deals listen I don't want to know
what you do you know oh why oh why you
took this thing last night or any of it
finish up get out don't come back
so really goes here root for it man
such a goddamn deadbeat
I always meet up with selling Skarsgard
isn't it yeah
oh is this the last time we saw her
wow
wow
well done Tony Gilroy hey I was
wondering if you maybe wrote director
whatever
Toby Hayes I know that I wonder if Tony
Gilroy wrote all them Maybe
I know he's very passionate about this
one project shows well it definitely
feels like his writing
oh yeah yeah a thousand percent if this
did not uh end like that
would just be like it wasn't just a week
to week yeah I mean I I I don't know not
trying to sound like we're
better than the average audience no it's
not an action-packed episode or some
Shader as like the most exciting
Cliffhanger
um but uh for My Personal Taste I'm like
just kind of show I've been kind of
crazy for all this time yeah yeah yeah
no totally because uh I I can't I can't
lie to you guys you know like I mean if
you've watched our reactions with
um any of these Star Wars shows Boba
Fett like obviously the Mandalorian mwah
love the hell out of the Mandalorian
uh but Boba Fett was really up and down
experience
Obi-Wan yeah fell into the mid for me by
the end had some like amazing moments
um for sure some amazing scenes but the
overall story that it told and how it
was told was real mid for me yeah I
remember the pilot being like who's the
part that's the first episode
and this had me gripped from go from the
go and then before you know it was a few
days ago I was talking with John like
you know I remember when I saw Rogue one
I really loved that film and then
re-watching it
I was like oh man you know I just kind
of
what was I saying I was saying like I
kind of just feel like they keep
regurgitating this this same goddamn
timeline and and it's all in the same
timeline it's a little bit before Rogue
one but it's not bad words this is
directly linked to the thing that you
love the most about Star Wars It's just
letting it be even though it will
connect and I think Tony Gilroy said
that by the end of season two it will
feed into Rogue one
um but yeah like it feels like you're
just here right now learning about this
moment in time rather than trying to get
to why this moment in time is going to
be relevant to something nostalgic in
the future or the past yeah it's like
we're Rogue one did not feel repetitive
to me by the time I went the first time
I saw it but because of everything
that's been coming out I was like oh
this kind of feels it's lost some of the
effect it doesn't have as much charm as
it did I I still like it to a degree
more little than a certain amount of
reason things
but yeah you can you can tell the
trouble that the production has yeah and
I really didn't feel that the first time
I watched it yeah and then but watching
this was like the word that keeps coming
to mind is this feels refreshing
refreshing is the word because it
doesn't feel like it's in a hurry no at
all it's a slow burn every time you meet
a character you feel the history of each
one of these characters and it's you
could feel the
you can feel the weight of the of the
Empire the backdrop of that without them
having to keep [ __ ] talking about it
without having to show like storm
troopers everywhere occupying yeah or
whatever yeah you you feel yeah in this
corner of the Galaxy at least as we've
known it for these you know 40 minutes
uh yeah you can feel how kind of uh how
the world has fallen a bit it feels it's
Star Wars so you know it's sci-fi
whatever and I and the Press person to
liken this too is is Ridley Scott or or
someone more relevant as today Denise
villain you as someone who really
captures something that goes for a more
grounded real world approach to a crazy
sci-fi story because this is you know
it's fictional Star Wars is unrealistic
but it feels freaking realistic yeah and
and it's also through the way the
characters interact and the way the
characters are responded we don't want
to talk for too long because it's three
episodes
um but for a starter I I really thought
what I'm surprised by with this
experience is I thought we would be
ending this video with it's just the
first episode so we're just getting
started so you know we're just gonna get
it going and see the next thing to be so
excited about this installment on its
own yeah and So Satisfied enough that I
could you know wait another week
just to chew on this yeah yeah yeah
because there's great visual language
like the way they're handling the
flashbacks without I mean we're watching
this early because they gave us the
first three early because we we're we've
been asked to interview um
I I think I think it's yeah the girl and
uh the corporate officer yeah we call
Gordon who fortunately
it's always refreshing when you don't
have a lot of people
because like the rule of thumb would
would doing interviews is like okay
focus on what you did like and just
don't mention what you don't like yeah
and you're like oh thank God they're
both this is gonna be easy yeah all
right yeah
um so yeah that that uh the the yeah
both with all the characters like I'm
intrigued by them without them having to
for them to Exposition dump whatever
their backstory is I'm like I I'm just
liking the immediacy of whatever the
moment is that we're with them because
it's such a striking tone uh that that
immerses you into into the dread and and
the way they've gotten me to
forget about where we're gonna land with
with Cassie and Andor so early on the
way they managed to make me not think
about that or be like no I ain't gonna
be captain no don't think I'll be
fighting rebellious
it sounds so simple but I think that is
one of the Achilles heels of a lot of
recent Star Wars attempts is that they
do spend a lot of time anywhere else but
here and now or or they're trying to
yeah hearken to things whereas this
really does a great job of drawing you
into these characters most of whom we're
all meeting for the first time and and
building off of what worked about
Cassian Andor in Rogue one and then
developing that but in these little in
these little ways I feel like every
scene gives you a set of circumstances
and then it lets the characters reveal
themselves through that it's like here's
what they're up against good writing man
yeah totally it's like good filmmaking
yeah because it seems like there are
multiple things on Tony Gilroy at the
moment's mind the writer's mind you know
because even in that scene where he and
Bix are talking for you know our first
time in the present at least uh like you
get multiple things out of that scene
both from the acting but also from the
dialogue because yeah he's trying to
arrange this deal or whatever but then
you learn about what her circumstances
are in this operation you also learn
about her personal life with that guy
who's like following her around just
like all these little bits and details
and then the actors take it that much
further and especially uh Gordon for
right now like all the different like
ticks and the ways in which he's so
wound up it's like they they allow I
comment down the music at one point and
and there's a lot of great music Across
these series but one thing I noticed in
this episode is they often would let the
music hang back during a lot of those
scenes just to let the circumstances and
the mannerisms really take you know
center stage and for to let you really
Relish in the ticks and emotions and the
things that are not said because so many
it's like you said there's a big theme
about you know lies and Distortion of
the truth and you look at both the
Empire and a rebellion of any sort and
you know there there's all these
clashing circumstances and perspectives
within all that and I feel like thus far
they've done nicely to draw this this
portrait of a world that is like gray
and seedy and I know everybody kind of
goes back to that moment in Rogue one
where he's like the lower class yeah
like it's really on the margins of
society where life is poverty is hard
and and I love that detail about like
he's in a brothel and then we're not
even supposed to have those and it was
an expensive brothel they weren't even
supposed to be able to afford though
like corporate greed like I like that
we're dealing with the morelana one like
we're dealing with just corporate
officers it's not exactly it's right
yeah it's not you know like we're here
with the Empire and the Imperials and
the building of death star or some [ __ ]
like like this just feels like different
than Rogue one and it feels like it fits
within the same world like it it
you're you always kind of hope that they
do their own thing a lot of the time and
they they really rarely feel like they
actually are able to
and with such a mature like it the first
10 minutes is some of the most mature I
feel maybe not 10 but like we were super
technical about it through at least
they'll tell you exactly though
it's like first 10 minutes yeah yeah
like the first 10 minutes it is very it
is it feels so adult it feels adults
like you're at a galactic brothel and
and uh the killing someone holds weight
it feels almost Western like yeah like
kind of like what Unforgiven did where
you know when he does kill that person
you could tell he's disturbed by what he
did despite the fact because because you
think that it's just gonna be one of
those things like I got 300 credits to
come up and messes them up or kills him
and he just walks away but it's cool but
no potato you feel the the pain of
taking taking a life and even the
corporate officer and the way he reacts
to it like there is pain to the
characters you know and I I think that
is such a I like having that haunting
effect and it is feels like it's just
doing its own thing
and not being so concerned and it gets
and thinking about him working with the
Rebellion when he's when he's
purposeless right now yeah he's just
looking out for himself he's a scoundrel
um he's got like a very minimal friends
everyone writes him off as that that guy
you loan money to and he ain't gonna pay
you back you know yeah and any 50
scavenger and he plays it with such
realism like it feels like such a real
person and every interaction he doesn't
feel so real it feels like a survival
skill even in the moments where he like
when he runs into the two guys in the
street who are trying to muscle him for
for their deposit or whatever like it
it's that thing of even in that like
that moment is more Charming than the
altercation in the alleyway but even
still you can feel the necessity in both
moments of like these are two different
versions of how I need to survive and I
and that moment in the alley is is
awesome because I think it it Harkens to
that moment in Rogue one where he he
caps the informant which I think lot of
people pointed to is like oh damn that's
kind of a stark moment and here I
thought they exchange is opening scene
yeah yeah
um and uh and it reminded me kind of of
that but in an even more you know just
unfurled kind of way where yeah like
that whole moment you spend so much time
within the tension and watching his face
like that was a that was a moment like
all these Star Wars shows look really
good and they often have like a sequence
or two with really astounding Framing
and visuals but that was one thing where
I was like it's the simplest choice just
to stay steady on him as the two voices
get closer and then as the altercation
reaches the head you start to cut and
you feel yeah the the real kind of pain
and Desperation when that guy's
bargaining with him and he's like he's
coming up with a cover story in that
moment and yeah like it's it's it's
fascinating and the dreariness doesn't
at least yet outweigh it doesn't over
outstay its welcome like it's dreary in
the right way it feels like stylistic
and substance at the same time style and
substance yeah and even the violent that
little bit of violence at the beginning
I love the way it was handled because it
felt like kind of real even when he got
hit it felt like when he turns his head
and he hits him yeah like just the way
how it it even though it had like the
sound effect the reaction to it and the
way it was done
wasn't like a yeah and then he like
Falls over or something it was just so
like it's kind of subtle and it felt
like it like it sells that and then the
way they're brawling yeah it sells that
this wasn't supposed to end this way
kind of messiness yeah yeah it was it
was a really gripping opening and then
now establishing who he is in this world
and it it gets me excited at the thought
of him finding a a real purpose in life
because you could tell what what other
cutting back between the present day
present day for the show the present day
for the show and then the past which I
really depreciate how they did they're
not at least on our screeners but
there's no subtitles yeah there's no
subtitles and I like that because you
are just picking up on body language and
facial expression and you're
understanding the communication via that
yeah and you could tell there's some
type of tragic thing that's about to
unfurl in this in this flashback here
so you know he's got some real painful
and then you know obviously talked about
a rogue one as well but gonna have some
painful backstory and you could see that
weight that he carries and yet he hasn't
done anything with that pain that that
is truly moving forward and doing some
good and I really get the impression
because even even in Rogue one there is
that little tidbit when he does join up
with Jenner or so at the end be being
like he's discovered you know like
there's some not so great things about
the rebellion and he wants to fight for
a something that's truly Noble and I
think we're gonna explore even the gray
side of the Rebellion that can be a
little dirty well yeah because I think
in the themes yeah in that watching so
many stories and circumstances be
sculpted into stories in this episode it
made me think of you know you think of
you know the Empire and and the
propaganda of that and and you know the
brainwashing that comes along with that
but you know in a way a rebellion is
just a concern of people just the same
and there can be desperate measures that
cross the line into you know that
philosophical debate of when are you you
know when are you sinking to your
enemies level or not and as much as you
know like the Rebellion generally in the
Star Wars universe is the right side of
things like yeah it can't be perfect
ideologically and I think if they choose
to explore the complication of that
because statecraft and all these things
are complicated and and they're not
black and white and I think it's I think
that's part of what feels so mature
about this is because you know in a lot
of Star Wars uh media there can be kind
of a boiling down of like no it's the
light in the dark and it's pretty easy
to tell which is which and I think it's
interesting of a show to perhaps
acknowledge yeah here's what is uh maybe
not so on the up and up about the
rebellion and how the Rebellion can
strive to be you know even more mobile
or whatever it is
um it makes you think I can't wait to um
I hope the next two episodes are good
but uh
I was like man I want to just go to
Twitter right now and be like guys guys
first episode of hand you're just
awesome it's terrific
um get ready
uh yeah I'm I'm surprised by how much I
enjoyed this I was like
because I love loved the trailers I have
loved the trailers
but when I first heard about this show
being announced I was like really want
to see an indoor show
I really want to watch this dreary guy
and then I watched Rogue one again and
when I rewatched Rogue one I was like
not one part of this movie makes me go I
want to see the backstory Explorer it's
kind of several seasons of this guy and
then that is kind of cool and like 10 to
15 minutes I was like I have never been
so relieved to watch a Star Wars show
before this is so good yeah every
everything is is good it is so good and
and to have something like Mandalorian
which feels so like this is pure Star
Wars and then to have and or which has
more of a scuzzy and I like how he's
exploring so much of these gray elements
and it has such a gray cinematography to
it I I like that you have on the flip
side there's much more grounded [ __ ]
okay and uh that feels dirtier and uh
but but does it feel like forced grit or
or Disney grit you know what I mean no
it feels natural it really it was
striking yeah because it felt like while
it doesn't cross the line too hard into
you know HBO yeah into anything past TV
14 territory it has a sensibility that
suggests that yeah like maybe undertones
that Disney got out of the way a little
bit and it said yeah like make something
that is a bit more mature not
necessarily adult but more mature yeah
yeah it's got it more sufficient it's
got that that uh War weary undertones or
Noir yeah yeah there's a sprinkling of
Sin City in there like it's it's ever so
slight but especially the way you meet
him in the beginning just like in that
coat and then that girl too yeah
yeah it's the classic setup of like I'm
looking for a girl have you seen her I
got this one lead you know but even even
the girl at the uh even the actress
whose name we should commit to memory
yes
um that even meeting her like that the
nothing she's not Femme Fatale but kind
of yeah yeah not necessarily the direct
opposition to the protagonist but yeah I
mean she she's obviously established as
somebody who can take care of herself
and is cunning
all right cool yeah I'm excited to watch
the next episode can't wait that was
refreshing I know I'm so happy so we're
so refreshing Jesus Christ I was not
expecting to be walking away going
refreshing yeah I hope people give this
a chance because I know that the hype
for it hasn't been as massive as they've
hoped but I hope the word of mouth I I
expect good word of mouth on this oh
yeah
under promise over deliver
all right guys well thank you for being
here
and uh since the Patron's day shop
Adelia Chamberlain
a Delia we have looked up your name on
Urban Dictionary yeah here it is
I think adelia's unique name and people
who have that name might be brave brave
Adelia a little embarrassing in some no
no let's do a different one
okay all right
Adelia Chamberlain
Adelia Adelia we've looked at what your
name means an urban dictionary here we
go Adelia is a cute kind nice looking
girl that she is Ruth mother F words she
hides her feelings a lot she can but she
also can write them out it may seem cold
but once you know her you can discover
how nice and kind she is yeah she
smacked me the first time we met but it
was worth it all right underneath that
smack yeah was preciousness there was
tender loving care in every moment that
smack even though she has been through a
lot she's still trying her best to
recover and make her surroundings happy
and smiling did you write this yourself
we did the Urban Dictionary for for
jokes usually these are the sir these
are I'm like this is not far off this is
like when you read your horoscope and
you're like oh actually yeah kind of
who's who the [ __ ] this is really
accurate oh thank you for updating Urban
Dictionary I assume your username is off
26. yeah great job Adelia you have
officially defined what the name of
Delia means for everyone across the
world of Wide Web stay cute kind and
nice love you dear
foreign
[Music]